[Music]
black holes are one of the most
devastating objects in space sucking up
everything around them but there's
another space phenomenon that's just as
destructive and it's known as a white
hole now what would happen if these two
objects met in space and fought each
other could something like this even
happen who would win and what is a white
hole anyway this is what if and here's
what would happen if a white hole fought
a black hole before we get to our fight
let's see what these two opponents are
all about in one corner of space we have
the black hole this legendary space
occurrence is probably pretty familiar
to you it's signature move is to consume
every piece of matter it comes in
contact with the white hole you're
probably less familiar with and it's
signature move is to expel energy rather
than sucking it in so with our two
fighters having completely opposite
attack strategies who would win despite
us not knowing much about our white hole
mystery opponent it's much more
experienced at conquering space than the
black hole is that's right the white
hole is a proper journeyman and has been
roaming space for millions of years
kicking butt and taking names that's
because scientists theorized that this
white hole used to be a black hole
scientists suspect that after millions
of years black holes will become white
holes and all the energy and matter they
consumed over the years will be expelled
back into space that being said when a
black hole becomes a white hole it might
not last very long so it will need to
act quickly if it wants to pick a fight
with a black hole and despite it being
different the white hole is just as
destructive as a black hole if not more
so the matter the white hole is ejecting
moves at the speed of light so it's safe
to say that the white hole is the
veteran fighter in this situation as
opposed to this up-and-coming black hole
but how much will its experience help it
after millions of years of causing
destruction throughout the universe our
two opponents finally meet they've
battled asteroids planets and even stars
but they always managed to survive now
they both face their greatest opponent
yet as these two massive forces approach
each other the black hole will instantly
gain the advantage the white hole will
do its best to prevent the black hole
from overtaking it but unfortunately it
really doesn't stand a chance that's
because the white hole has no choice but
to spit energy at its opponent although
it was able to defend itself against
everything else in the universe
unfortunately the black hole is its one
true match the mass the white hole is
expelling is also being turned into
energy for the black hole
this won't be a quick battle either as
the black hole can feed on the white
hole for thousands of years and as it
keeps feeding the black hole is getting
larger and larger and now the black hole
is ready for the finishing blow it
completely swallows the white hole now
that it's consumed so much energy how if
black hole is more massive than ever it
might be as big as the Messier 87 which
is 38 billion kilometers across
for reference that's three million times
larger than Earth so if a white hole and
the black hole collided we'd have a
massive black hole roaming around the
universe destroying everything in its
path
[Music]
and if it were anywhere near us well
that would mean humanity would be in
some pretty big trouble but we'll leave
that story for another what if
[Music]